par exemple j'en ai première sur bernard
montiel enfin
bernard montiel n'a pas été bloqué à
marrakech c'est simplement qu'il ne
voulait pas payer son billet au prix
fort
arrivent en retard et payer moins cher
son billet source benjamin castaldi
à chaque année ça s'est fait assez
totalement vrai il a fait ça c'est vrai
le lobby et robin plus cher le dimanche
que le lundi pourquoi qu'il ait pas
voulu payer trois fois plus cher pour
ont bien travaillé d'accord elle
reviendra et on va le tout 5 et vous
avez très peu venir
peut-être confirmer ou infirmer où il a
confirmé je vais maintenant lui journée
il a raison
j'aime la franchise montagne il arrivera
vous même pour la raison c'est pas
savoir le prix du retour de soirée
dramatique de ma ba oui le lendemain
c'est 80 balais et le dimanche et 450
500 banon si si non mais tu perds ta
chronique comme un gros niveau ben oui
mais bon personnel ou mascouche et
passera en fait un problème et non il
n'y avait pas les financières n'y avait
pas de correspondants ce matin la
prochaine fois rester plus longtemps
isabelle d'un acceptèrent placement de
produit pour des bijoux en revanche elle
n'a pas encore trouvé d'accord financier
pour un partenariat
est alliée stana c'est benjamin castaldi
raconte excellent travail sauf que sauf
que maintenant elle a découvert un
bonheur pour les connaisseurs c'est le
placement de produits mais non c'est
incroyable pas ses produits lcd mais non
mais là les places directement rayon
droite
[Rires]
elle été débauché pour tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est autour du cou vous
doutez bien que je vais pas sa part par
goût alors est-ce qu'elle a payé bien
sûr il
ya d'ailleurs et elle a eu une demande
incroyable et les fauteuils des filles
pour remonter les escaliers ou les
dessins
bien sûr remplacer jean lefebvre
et apparemment la discussion et a prôné
bouffonne
sévérité mais vous pensez réellement que
les bio sur massés pour moi ouais non
vous n'aurez que c'est vrai bien sûr que
c'est vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais même vous donner le début du
spot elle doit arriver devant son
fauteuil et de faire bloc favorables
offertes et moi opca tenable non bien
sûr c'est vrai que c'est vrai alors
c'est sûr il a raison on le sait et
surtout data foutez de moi il ya trop de
détails la bête est restée celle là
dessus où il est le meilleur
valérie temps qui dit toujours non mais
bien non non mais attendez entre l'oeil
de verre
[Rires]
je
vous jure que ccc ccc drôle oui c'est le
pied droit mais c'est faux agents mais
j'aimerais bien en avoir un sas après
celle d'hier mais
oui ça m'agace ali s'est vanté d'avoir
fait plus d'audience en passant chez
michel drucker que cyril hanouna sur le
même canapé rouge source chroniqueur
anonyme qui ne veut pas de problèmes
mais qui souhaite que la vérité de
peillon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors je n'en peux plus parce que donc
c'était de la vanité ou que ça touchait
bernard montiel et vous non ou c'est
sacré et castaldi mais depuis plusieurs
jours arrivent très tôt
exceptionnellement tôt en loges pour
faire ce discours la serbie au qanoun a
fait du piquet de l'audience donc de
l'oseille je vis une deuxième vie de
vedette mais benjamin vous n'êtes plus
rien
c'est pas rien pas grand chose oui
quelle bande de chiens modèle vous
démarrez ouaf ouaf ou
presque mais c'est sérieux ça s'est
passé avec lyon s'est jamais jamais je
n'irai qui va démarrer à la fin du
tirage
où il avait pas des fistons des
décalages et un énorme dossier comme
quoi delphine wespiser et benjamin
castaldi nom est aperçu nu dans une
bouche des loges de la factory
abaissant
les deux ça comment ça c'est que moi qui
étais nuit là
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous expliquer ça merci beaucoup
heureusement que c'est l'heure du bain
et que ma femme ne regarde pas
l'émission
prend son bain forcé mais non mais bien
alors nous
donc non mais c'est vrai que c'était y
ait chez dupuis et dejan ya deux ans et
officiers sont que des navets avait
besoin de se doucher et en fait les
douches de des loges étaient et sont
était coincé boucher voit la belle
époque au secours
et moi en bon samaritain oui bien
évidemment sur bien sûr c'est bon ça m'a
rien
[Rires]
demandé
si cela ne la dérangeait pas que je
vienne l'aider j'ai évidemment éviter
des ans comme ça donc je ne vois rien ab
non je peux même vous dire que ce jour
là exceptionnellement benjamin castaldi
avait les yeux très ouvert
sachez le ce n'était pas ses yeux
donc j'ai donc je lui ai sauvé de cette
douche ou un bain est prisonnière
du service et à mon avis c'est bien vous
qui l'aurait sauvé les autres sont
celles à bernard montiel revue
systématiquement que ce soit un
stagiaire qui lui met son micro source
l'équipe de tpm paix qui veut que la
vérité éclatera
c'est vrai
merci
au micro il fait attendre les gens qui
doivent se déplacer en loge et l'exigent
un titulaire dès que c'est un stage et
réduit le micro et mal mis ce type est
imbuvable
déchiré geste est vrai j'espère que vous
n'allez pas le croire c'est moi qui ai
donc ça brillait toujours les mêmes
vannes je vous équiper j'ai déjà équipés
[Applaudissements]
et
ça c'est énorme netflix a contacté la
production pour faire un partenariat
avec des chroniqueurs bankable 1 et puis
que la production a proposé nicolas
pernikoff et gilles verdez nous n'avons
plus aucune nouvelle
pendant les briefings quand on aborde un
sujet où il est question d'argent
isabelle demande systématiquement qu'on
lui fasse la conversion en anciens
francs matthieu delormeau j'avais dit
anonymat et mouzon me ne sais pas me
tenir ça pourrait être vrai c'est pas
faux a gagné 2,5 millions d'anciens
francs
ah merde c'est pour moi tu as à cyril
prendre un malin plaisir à lâcher des
gaz au dos rond et bruyant dans les
boutiques de luxe sur lesquels ils
seront source lino le fils de cinéma
c'est vrai forcément sabrina m
la vérité sort de la bouche des enfants
qu'ils soient du leur on se trouve que
j'étais à côté de votre fils qui vous a
incriminé donc je me dois de le dire aux
test matches que j'ai toujours à mon
fils tu dis il m'a incrimine impunément
comme ça vous n'avez jamais pété dans
une boutique de luxe je n'ai jamais pété
townshend
marvano des boutiques de luxe ensemble
ouais on a rendez vous demain après midi
donc si vous dites est vrai j'avais mon
fils mon fils a cru que j'avais pété
c'est juste mon roi chaussures qui s'est
fait remarquer et je vous jure que c'est
vrai je suis prêt de l'argentin ont fait
beaucoup de shopping avec lui j'ai déjà
pété jeudi au caire une boutique et
évacué ses terres
[Rires]
aïe aïe aïe castaldi refuse que
quiconque de la production touchés
baisse car ils laissent dessus
l'étiquette et les ramène au magasin
se faire rembourser source l'équipe
maquillage coiffure c'est vrai c'est
ouais c'est partiellement vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai ce que vous avez vu
toutes les peaux qui s'est longtemps
mais quand on met un micro il met tout
le temps du scotch et ça abîme les
vestes etc ne sont plus mes vestes pour
cause de budget c'est à cause de
l'argent
je veux qu'on mette du scotch parce que
je les rends les belges soient pas
d'accord ouais c'est tout papa pas les
soucis d'économie ouais c'est comme ces
femmes
je dérange
et n'inspire pas là mais il a fallu un
laver c'est pas son truc les cherry hill
pendant les pubs guillaume genton
s'entraîne à signer des autographes dans
le vide car il est persuadé que des fans
dont bientôt lui ont demandé sur
géraldine maillet oui c'est vrai que
j'aimerais beaucoup de souci pour mon
voisin de droite il a atteint de
mégalomanie aiguë mais je fais ici il
n'ya pendant toutes les séquences quand
il ya des invités pendant la pub et tout
ça il s'entraîne à faire des autographes
et une dès qu'il en a 100 sur notoriété
c'est pas vrai qu'on lui demande
toujours autographes dans la rue et qui
veut avoir l'air à l'aise non savais que
ma carrière a pris un tournant depuis
que j'ai fait ma mère est une célébrité
c'est vrai par contre j'ai une contre
piquet ce sujet j'ai pas le temps de
mettre dans la boîte c'est que mathieu
delambre sortant de l'émission
distribuer des photos dédicacées de
lioujas il y en a toujours sur lui dans
son sac et j'ai une preuve sur dernis
que j'en ai récolté les gens dit non non
je gère que ses vrais débuts
ça tous les soirs ils enlèvent bachelot
non c'est vrai ça tu es de l'orme
animateurs et j'en avais aussi un stock
d'nrj12 qui restait aussi non j'ai un
stock bas on avait à l'époque bernard
des photos comme ça et c'est vrai que
j'en ai toujours sur moi c'est le
plaisir aux gens je redistribue beaucoup
d'entre eux et heureusement j'en ai de
ses bisous à toi alors faites gaffe
parce que la mairie s'est plaint de
parce qu'elle retrouve plein dans la rue
générant
un volume trop de fils
[Rires]
en apprenons qu'à la dette aux cadeaux
de noël de cyril à ses collaborateurs
valerie déclaré à cette année c'est cool
parce que l'année dernière c'était
vraiment de la merde fabien de lettres
collaborateurs ami à moi qui se trouvait
à proximité de la scène de crime se
confirme complètement c'est quoi
l'histoire à l'année dernière vous avez
offert un dvd de nos propres émissions c
serait assez pour que vous vous
regardiez pour qu'on se regarde oui on
n'a pas un ego démesuré cette année
c'est quoi le cadeau ce qui suppose un
chargeur de téléphone c'est pas ouf
j'étais en forme a dit j'ai pas encore
validé il ya deux ans c'était un
calendrier obéir à crever quand même
bravo à ce terrible non mais franchement
là eh oui mais à deux hommes n'est pas
rater un rendez vous
donc je vous dire mais vous dites moi
merci c'est un chargeur par ex un
chargeur ça c'est un très beau cadeau
merci c'est
l'horreur on ne sait pas si c'est par et
l on vit ou par intérêt et bernard
montiel a chiné laurence ça y est à
plusieurs reprises en loge
benjamin castaldi on est la source c'est
vrai qu'est ce que c'est que ça t'a fait
c'est vrai il est sur les côtes de lens
ayessa année très joli nom et 13 janvier
j'avais remarqué qu'il est extrêmement
proche
et c'est vrai c'est vrai ce passe
quelque chose mais alors vous deux
j'aime bien ce qu il va
scanner dans balances ton pote son
passage à l'émission non c'est une femme
extrêmement brillante
c'est une femme extrêmement brillante
très agréable de compagnie
balade et le soir c'est pas la braconne
[Rires]
et à paris on est chargé reste accepte
une à le dire c'est une femme formidable
exceptionnel vous avez déjà dire à
cracher pas c'est tout brillante ça nous
regarde c'est qu'on a fait et fait
l'amour bernard à en 1915 mais non pour
de vrai c'était ça me regarde sa
possible par le vote entre amis et
biscuits mais c est l est très regardée
comme les jolies oui alors et vous
pourriez vous pourriez sauter le pas
so t
il être posé la question de borel non
mais elle vous adore elle l'a dit est ce
que vous pourriez avoir une aventure et
cohérent ça promet alors ce tapage si
elle est d'accord
mais on se parle beaucoup vous savez
l'or c'est barbare c'est du sérieux non
parce que tous les jours et c'est un
savant vous ça bouge encore oui vous
soufflant bien dessus peut-être
donc il faut juste voir le jour de
l'anniversaire
non mais non ça bouge encore je sais
même pas lui-même pour le moment c'est
très intellectuelle ah oui mais vous ça
fait longtemps que vous n'avez pas oui
c'est vrai non mais sérieux les
empêche pas sexuel oui les séries non
mais série dont il pas du tout fait qu
el baba cérémonie les sirènes et
exactement s'est activé comme moi vous
êtes c'est un très
beau très beau
et doux donc vous ne serrez
vous aimez lire et changer tout ça ouais
c'est ça que je veux avec une femme
alors qu'elle regardait interdisant
cette voulait qu'une femme voilée à la
pudeur
a misé sur lui sur la carte et qu'on
peut dire serrer brémois je suis
cérébrale vous n'êtes pas chez vous dire
oui à delphine qui me connaît très bien
à moi j'en sais rien
au rayon des plans médiatiques et quand
même côté que mon ami reconnaît mais
bien sûr c'est vrai non mais oui vous
êtes très cérébral voilà un vrai progrès
sur le feeling et sur les atomes crochus
avec les gens c'est très important pour
vous tous qu'avec moi le raid cérébrale
allemande à guillon dans le jacuzzi est
ce qu'il est cérébral donc pour moi s'il
ya un mot pour définir s'il sait
cérébrale est ce moi et quand on saute
dessus ça fonctionne aussi ou pas vous
ah non non non pas d'où ça ne bouge plus
une
merde ah oui c'est vrai ouais donc ça y
est c'est fini la digue était sur pause
vous avez dit que wii music
[Rires]
ils en arrivent
à nontron charrues c'est de lui la santé
ou là où la
capa sa pension je les remets mon lot
cyril hahn m'a dit qu'il ne sort jamais
pourtant il aurait été vu dans une
discothèque jusqu'à très tard
matin avec des amis à lui oui
la discothèque c'est le gpo la cité
c'est le mosnac non oui mais très bien
je peux confirmer la version pc il est
libéré il est rentré c'était samedi
dernier après la large victoire de
l'équipe de france de football c'est de
moi j'avais envie de fêter ça
7h30 non parce qu'il m'a appelé en fait
qu'il m'appelait 8h15 non non la gironde
de boîte non non non pas du tout pas dû
rentrer
[Rires]
avec des jets doit sortir un peu j'avais
même j'ai fêté ma victoire au paddle
voilà ça oui et donc j'ai donc saisi g
zoug et oui jésus qui c'est pas lui qui
fait les vecteurs l'équipe de foot c'est
avec l'équipe de foot chez dire j'ai
fêté les deux en même temps c'est très
grave
matthieu delormeau note qu est ce qui se
passe vous avez un truc ou
deux cas d'excès sur des espèces de
chênes
téléfoot
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
matthieu delormeau même pas d'émission
moustiques car ça demande financière
aurait été jugée indécente et digne d'un
prime de 10 prime meilleur sur tf1
c'est qui la source c'est moi
[Rires]
ça va choquer les téléspectateurs mais
je vais donner le chiffre non non non de
ville
[Rires]
n'y croyais pas donc si on interrogeait
la chaîne et je vais vous donner parce
que je préfère est rigoureux la citation
de la tête face à la chaîne ce sont des
chiffres délirants à la nique aux ce que
vous avez demandé donc c'est une somme à
cinq chiffres et il a dit j'étais prêt à
remettre un sixième du monde délirant
que je me compare à nikos oui donc -
dont il est au dessus de nico se
batturent à mr sim animations plus rien
beaucoup nico excuse moi tu es en
talents je suis désolé les mecs qui je
le dis franchement moi qui suis visé
leur séant talent inné loin devant le
cnsof bowie nikos il fait le travail
paye ta race mais matthieu delormeau
c'est un génie après la barre vous avez
un animateur et un gel d'avoirs c'est
pour cela qu'il a été arrêté
helikos j'aime beaucoup des dicos
stadistes et matthieu delormeau thomas
qu'un voyage il a mérité
mais n'a baissé en plus vraiment nikos
est bien son talent poétique aux bons et
la meinau rien quoi tu sais c'est pas un
phénomène est propre les phénomènes y en
a 4 50 et les sans rigoler et matthieu
delormeau on fait bien mais moi je vous
parlais chiffrement des phénomènes comme
à 4,5 et mathieu tu fais partie des
données jean luc reichmann est un
phénomène dans son domaine franchement
c'est vrai qu'il est très fort voilà
c'est un génie de la route un génie a
bien là donc mathieu toi + moi tu es
bien au dessus de tout cela d'accord
mais pourquoi vous n'avez pas de donner
l'argent qui a demandé à la
vérité parce que pourquoi génie parce
que pourquoi souvent un artiste places
payées en suis pas un génie lui vous
êtes un artiste et l'argent ça on passe
complètement tué six gars vous avez fait
sa liste c'est pourquoi il a fait ça 1
voilà pour faire un coup d'éclat mais
sera très content chez lui ce soir sans
l'argent faisait son petit son petit
coin sont pas nés tu feras heureux comme
un pape voisins dit voilà
je suis pas ton
ami johnny hollyday génie dans le passé
un bac 4 5 vous en tant que parti a bien
molli ces travaux mais reichmann il a
même ajouté impayable iceman et
travaille pas gratos alors détrompez
vous
voilà voilà il s'arrange en tout cas il
n'a pas les mêmes émoluments que
matthieu delormeau
beaucoup moins
gourmand moins exigeants sur le
chiffrage ils s'adorent il a refusé le
chien couché un génie mais merci hein ah
oui ah ouais quoi le 12 novembre dernier
dans l'anonymat et profitant d'une
journée offre chamakh à s'allier se
serait rendu dans une clinique de
chirurgie esthétique pour organiser un
rafistolage total source monsieur c'est
vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai rendez-vous une semaine avant
mais lorsque nous avons appris un peu
tardivement que nous ne travaillons pas
les 11 et 12 novembre il a décommandé le
rendez vous c'était fermé le 11 il y est
allé le 12 ils à négocier une ristourne
comme d'habitude ce que je ne sais pas
vu sa tête je pense qu'il a fait
l'opération qui était une lourde
opération mais j'en suis pas sûr vous
avez fait le 12 vous avez repris un
rendez-vous s'agit n'y aura pris ce
qu'il a fait
vous voulez que je dise vraiment jeu il
s'est fait refaire le ventre alors
allemand mais non alors que jeudi
j'avais effectivement alors c'est pas
refaire levante viable technologie qui
permet de recoller la dombes reconfirmer
ma formation sauf que vous avez pas la
fin d'information il trouve que
malheureusement la personne qui devait
pratiquer cet internaute qui n'est pas
chirurgicale mais qu'une intervention
bénigne état de recoller la peau sur le
muscle a faim dans le muscle qui épouse
parfaitement les abdominaux pavel un
masque alors je vous explique benjamin
castaldi avant et l'époque qu'il avait
la peau là et le muscle après muscle est
hélas il a profité de son quad à mes
rendez vous avec lui avait sa peau
cannes est le cas les deux
livrets de révision pris rendez-vous et
malheureusement le la personne qui
devait le médecin qui me fait recette de
cette opération a trompé le coc vide non
je n'embrasse donc je n'ai pas pu en
avez pas marre de faire des opérations
non mais je me permets de
vous savez je suis dispo non non il va
c'est pas ça mais jamais leur papa de
plastique c'est vous êtes en plastique
mat